no hay consenso en europa sobre la
vacunación con la aparición de la
variante omicron úrsula von der leyen
pidió abrir el debate de la vacunación
obligatoria
cómo podemos afrontar y pensar en una
potencial obligatoriedad de la
vacunación en la unión europea se
necesita una discusión esto necesita una
aproximación común pero es una discusión
que necesitamos afrontar hast villette
la mayoría de ministros de salud de los
países comunitarios se han posicionado
en contra de la medida por el momento
solo en austria será obligatoria la
vacunación para mayores de 14 años a
partir del 1 de febrero una medida que
ha causado protestas en el país
aquí
estoy aquí porque estoy en contra de la
vacunación obligatoria estoy a favor de
los derechos humanos y la violación de
los mismos debería pararte quienes se
nieguen a vacunarse podrán enfrentar
multas de hasta 3.600 euros por su parte
grecia multar a los mayores de 60 años
que no se vacunen a partir del 15 de
enero en otros países tienen soluciones
más ingeniosas eslovaquia dará 300 euros
a todos los mayores de 60 que quieran
vacunarse la medida sin embargo causa
escepticismo en algunos ciudadanos toma
nota aquí nada son aquellos que no
querían vacunarse antes de los 300 euros
tendrán la misma opinión ahora no
cambiarán la opinión de la gente en
otros países comunitarios- la vacunación
general obligatoria no entra en los
planes de sus respectivos gobiernos
entre ellos suecia dinamarca portugal o
españa en donde más del 80% de la
población cuenta con al menos una dosis